voilà milkshake c'est sucré comme tu es
pas plutôt un café
ok et ben 2g xplay et est ce que c'est
possible d'en faire un au café cours
sans sucre sans les cafés un nom un
milkshake au café course ensuite sonné
compliqué charge en ald
aujourd'hui j'ai fait un test de
grossesse et je vais pas le garder parce
qu'ils étaient négatifs et que j'ai fais
pipi dessus et donc le test
ma mère pense qu'un tatouage s'est abîmé
son corps pour un truc on regrettera
forcément mais elle me demande quand
même ce que j'attends pour faire un
enfant
est ce que c'est normal d'avoir peur
pour un être qui n'est pas encore
réellement la peur de le voir grandir de
voir mon compte bancaire ça me nuit se
projette la flamme blanche à ces enjeux
j'ai peur qu'ils se sentent seuls
inadaptée qu'il ne trouve pas vraiment
sa place je voudrais lui assurer que
c'est normal parce que les chiens ne
font pas des chats et promis un jour il
en rigolera et surtout qu'il ne se fasse
pas de souci parce que je le trouverai
un super psy qui lui dira que s'il se
sent différent c'est juste qu'il est
comme tout le monde finalement
qu'une paille n'importe quoi l'un des
quatre choses j'ai peur qu'ils ne
s'aiment pas qu'ils ne m'aiment pas
parmi ses peurs pour lui j'ai peur
qu'ils aient peur pour moi j'aimerais
lui dire que tu fasse trop de bêtises
autant face pas assez ce sera mon rôle à
moi de m'inquiéter d'accord alors je
t'attendrai jusqu'à 2h du mat il le faut
que tu sois bien rentré tu peux poser
ton téléphone de mon téléphone deux
secondes qu'il te plaît
t'inquiète pas je serai toujours là
enfin non alors je ne serai plus là mais
je ne ferai pas exprès en tout cas je
vais me battre pour rester le plus
longtemps possible à tes côtés
et puis quand je serai plus là je
garderai toujours un oeil sur toi si tu
es en bonne compagnie dans un lit par
exemple la bombe à faire un petit au
premier mais je n'abandonnerai pas qu'à
droite comme jeu alors il paraît que
c'est instinctif que je serais tout de
suite il a plutôt besoin de croquettes
ou de pathé mais parfois je me dis que
c'est trop tard parti comme c'est un
jour je vais aller acheter des couches
et en fait elles seront pour moi je
crois que j'ai surtout peur d'avoir
envie de donner la vie de réaliser en
écrivant ma dernière page que je n'ai
même pas eu le temps de laisser deux
meilleurs enfants à ma planète
l'horloge tourne même quand on ne met
pas de pile dedans c'est partout hier
est embêté la dame non mais ils
m'embêtait pas
ou peut-être que je me prends juste trop
la tête
[Musique]
je peins ça va j'ai encore le temps à